and, accordingly, any decision of
this kind is null and void for the Russian
Federation from the point of view of law,
no one will arrest him; rather, if we
protect him, the people of Russia
will be very sorry,
I don’t think this is possible to be honest
[music]
Well, the sound of him and such grief
brought us insoles  it’s just the insoles from the
ruins, but the insoles carrying the spouts are
bolted And how many of our all kinds of
people are just forever to the workshop on the hatch in 100,
I’m still guessing for them half will be
punished
So the soul of the rich already from Gali guilt
25 starts just Rhubarb of madness I
love found
I think  what kind in practice do you think
it will
really change, no one will,
unfortunately,
I think that only when
death will be